you
hey everybody it's almost finale time at
beginning all kinds of questions about
Viserion the night king so I figured
it's time to start talking about endgame
theories for them because this is not
slowing down at all there are a couple
big questions to answer so we know that
this is going into season eight the
night king is making it south of the
wall but what is he going to do with
Vissarion aside from just patrol around
the army of the Dead they've lost some
of their number but presumably they
break south of the wall they replenish
those and then some exponentially so
what we're talking about killing the
Nike and killing Viserion you have to
sort of clarify what the rules are like
what is Viserion now is he a white or is
he more like the White Walkers because
there's a big difference the Sirian
would still needed his tissue otherwise
he couldn't fly in whites decomposed
unlike the White Walkers
who's seemingly aged but maybe at a much
slower rate there's a lot of questions
about the way White Walkers age because
Craster's babies get turned but once he
touches them and his magic takes hold do
they just immediately sprout into
fully-grown White Walkers or do they age
at the same rate that other human beings
would I think the idea is that his magic
takes hold of them and they grow at a
much accelerated rate but they still
decompose because there's only a handful
of White Walkers that we know of here
but way back during season four there's
all of these standing in the background
and John has killed a couple himself
Samwell killed one so licious assumed
that for hundreds of years people have
been offering sacrifices like Craster
there have been white walkers that have
grown died off and then replenished
through new babies that have come along
but I've gotten so many questions about
vissarion now because he's been turned
by the night king will he still grow so
a lot of people saw the blue eye and
they just took that to mean that he was
like the White Walkers but White's also
have blue eyes so that's not necessarily
a confirmation right now just based on
the evidence the show has given us I'm
treating him like a bigger more
complicated version of the white polar
bear that we saw earlier in the episode
I think the idea now is that he has all
the same abilities that he had before he
breathes fire because if they're gonna
take down the wall and he's going to
help it's gonna have to be fire people
are like will he breathe frost the
really easy conclusion to make there is
that frost isn't gonna help bring down a
giant ice wall you're gonna need fire so
wouldn't it be cool if he breathes blue
fire and that's just a function of the
night Kings magic but he can ride him
like a normal mount he can send him on
patrol so the night king can just walk
around on the ground while Viserion is
strafing or doing whatever he wants he
can also use him as a recon tool so he
can see through vissarion's eyes the way
that bran sees through the eyes of the
raven now they haven't completely
defined the night Kings powers all of
his abilities flow through the children
of the forest so anything that they were
capable of doing the night King is
probably capable of doing a version of
that too but in turning him into a
weapon it sounds like they just imbued
him with a bunch of extra abilities on
top of that this nightmare of nature
that could raise the dead in control
massive armies he can control all of the
whites simultaneously and like they said
you kill him you kill everyone else
because he created them all so this is a
really important idea because the big
question is is what kind of final battle
are we moving towards will they actually
make it past Winterfell or is that where
the final battle is gonna take place and
it'll just be over a couple of episodes
like it'll all just happen up there
because if they make it past Winterfell
it'll probably be because they've washed
over it like a biblical plague so think
about how heartbreaking it was when the
Bolton's took Winterfell if the army of
the Dead were to take Winterfell that
would almost be too much but if they
don't make it south then Battle of
Gondor style like your final battle
takes place there even though the Gondor
of Game of Thrones is down in King's
Landing it would be a nice way to sort
of deflect for the battle for the Iron
Throne everybody says that it doesn't
matter well if the final battle takes
place at Winterfell then it really
wouldn't matter and pretty soon we're
probably gonna have all of our important
characters up in the north anyway
because they're either going to
Winterfell or going to the wall so you
have this whole idea that there's not
gonna be anything interesting happening
in the south so it paints a very
different picture than what I think
people's expectations were when the
series first started because King's
Landing has been the center of
everything way back in season four we
saw the shadow of a dragon flying over
it that was a vision that bran had had
that might have been a vision of the
future with Daenerys flying over King's
Landing on drogon because we haven't
seen her in any of the promos and I
think that's just to maintain some
surprise because when she
at this big meeting that they're having
she'll arrive on dragon back so there
will be a dragon over King's Landing but
in the way that the series sold Ned
Stark is the protagonist during season
one I also think it's a misdirect with
King's Landing in the Iron Throne
Daenerys had all those visions of it in
ruins with snow falling on the ground
you could take that as a vision of the
future the night King bringing Viserion
to King's Landing and just destroying
everything but after the fact as the
visions are sort of explained to
Daenerys there are things that might
have happened or it could have happened
had things been different so I think
this isn't meant to be a literal future
I think it's meant to be a combination
of futures like maybe Daenerys with her
dragons didn't listen to Tyrion destroys
everything and then winter eventually
comes because they did not come together
so whether he makes it that far south or
whether they hold him at Winterfell they
need to kill the night king and they
need to kill Viserion there was one
really big way for killing a dragon
whether he was undead or not earlier
this season there's the giant scorpion
that Braun took drogon down with they'll
have to use that but I think that
they'll also have to add some dragon
glass or maybe even to make a Valyrian
steel bolt the characters haven't
learned how to do that yet but Gendry
master blacksmith could borrow or take
somebody's Valyrian sword melt that down
and turn it into a Valyrian steel bolt I
think it would be a little disingenuous
if there wasn't at least a little bit of
a big battle of the bastards situation
where you actually have a big pitched
battle army of the Dead versus the
United forces of the south but really
you need to get someone in close to the
knight King so that requires a dragon in
someone who's really agile so a lot of
Arya Stark theories flying around but
you could either drop her from one of
the other dragons but if you're unable
to bring Viserion down and the knight
King remains on his back out of reach
you could try to use one of the dragons
to airlift her in and get her clothes
with her dagger whether or not that be
effective we've never actually seen
someone fight the Nike in close combat
so you have to imagine that his badass
is the White Walkers are the night king
is an extra level above that the smarter
way would probably be to take Viserion
down with a scorpion bolt then get
someone in close to the knight King
because if you killed the knight King
while they were flying in the air per
the rules Viserion would die immediately
and then who
ever went in to kill the night king
would just freefall until somebody
picked him up so you guys can let me
know in the comments which method do you
prefer someone is gonna have to kill the
night king I mean it will definitely be
someone gets in close and ganks him and
takes down most of the army that hasn't
already been killed by the United forces
of the south but do you prefer someone
do that while they're flying through the
air or after they've already killed
Viserion using one of the Scorpions but
as sort of a tangent to that people
wondering what's gonna happen with Ragle
and drogon so you have two on one now
they'll have to at least attempt some
sort of aerial Spitfire battle with all
three of them but I really do feel like
drogon and ragle will make it out of
this or at least in time to lay new
dragon eggs and fertilize them Daenerys
has been barren for all this time she
believes that she's not going to have
any more children
she believes there won't be any more
dragons so I think the big surprise is
is that she will eventually get pregnant
again and have a child is sort of
flowing from that new dragons will also
be born Early's dragon eggs will be laid
we really don't know how long it takes
for them to gestate that could be
multiple lifetimes so the characters on
the show now might be dead before more
dragons are born in per maester aemon in
the books we find out the dragons are
sort of asexual they're neither male nor
female so whether or not they choose to
do that it is possible for them to mate
but let me know watch all your Nike
Vissarion theories in the comments below
but because we've been talking a lot
about Daenerys being childless I'll talk
a little bit about the prophecy in my
next bonus video and then obviously my
finale video so all that's come in
really soon
the HBO now giveaway is still going on
all you have to do to enter that just be
a subscriber leave a comment on this
video congratulations to last week's
winner Chris Whitehead please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details while
you wait for everything you can click
here for my finale video and you can
click here for the trailer again thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight